الاخبار اهلا بكم اما الاضراب الشامل
اليوم مختلف المحافظات الفلسطينيه في
الضفه الغربيه حدادا على ارواح شهداء جديد
وقد اغلقت المحل التجاريه ابوابها استجابه
لدعوه الفصائل الفلسطينيه الى الاضراب
ياتي ذلك في وقت يستعد فيه الفلسطينيون
لتشييع الشهداء السته
ظهر اليوم في جنين
وكانت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه قد اعلنت
استشهاد سته فلسطينيين برصاص قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال عمليه اقتحامها
جنين وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان من بين من
قتلهم في جنين منفذه عمليات حواره وقالت
كتيبه جنين انها اسقطت مسيره اسرائيليه
شاركت في الاقتحام
وقد دانعت كتائب القسام الشهيد عبد الفتاح
خروشه منفذ عمليه حواره ودعت الى تصعيد
المقاومه كما قالت حركه فتح ان ثلاثه من
الشهداء ينتمون لكتائب شهداء الاقصى
التابعه للحركه من جانبها قالت حركه
الجهاد الاسلاميين مقاتلها اشتبكوا مع
جنود الاحتلال في جنين
هذا وشرك مئه الفلسطينيين في تظاهره وسط
مدينه رام الله تنديدا باقتحام قوه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لمخيم جنين
كما نظمت الفصائل الفلسطينيه مسيره في
قطاع غزه تنديدا باقتحام قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لمخيم جنين بالضفه الغربيه
اعلن رئيس شركه باجنا الرياضيين عن سيطره
قوه
ان كل المنطقه الشرقيه من المدينه الواقعه
شرق نهر ضخ موتكا اصبحت تحت سيطره قوته
بشكل كامل
وصف الكرمل التقارير الصحفيه الغربيه بشان
تفجير نورت ستريم بانها ليست غريبه وتفوح
منها رائحه الجريمه الوحشيه والهدف منها
هو تشتيت الانتباه عن الفاعل الحقيقي
وقال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي ان واشنطن ما تزال
تنتظر انتهاء التحقيق الاوروبي من شان
تفجير الخط من جهته قال مستشار الرئيس
الاوكراني انه لا علاقه لبلاده بالهجوم
وكانت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز نقلت عن
مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم ان مهاجمي خط نورت
ستريم العمل الماضي كانوا على الارجح من
اوكرانيا او روسيا ولم يشارك في العمليه
اي امريكيا او بريطاني وكشفت الصحيفه ان
واشنطن رجعت معلومات استخباراتيه جديده
تشير الى ان مجموعه مواليه لاوكرانيا نفذت
الهجوم على خطوط الانابيب
قال رئيس وزراء مالي ان بلاده لم تتخلى عن
التعاون مع فرنسا وان الفرنسيين ارادوا ان
يفرضوا على الماليين ما يقومون به وانهم
قرروا المغادره بعد مجيء حكومه لا تروق
لهم على حد وصفه وفي مقابله خاصه مع جزيره
اكد رئيس وزراء ايمالي ان هناك ادله لدى
بلاده تؤكد ان بعض الارهابيين كانوا على
تواصل مع فرنسا
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]